(ding)
(bright bass music)
- [Female Host] So, how
are we feeling today?
- Excited.
I'm, like, kind of
nervous for some reason.
- First I'm not,
but now he make me.
- She's not.
Hi, my name's Brian, I'm 25,
I'm a photographer and
videographer here in LA.
This is my beautiful mom.
- I'm Cindy.
I'm a nail salon owner.
I'm very happy to come today for the show.
- Yeah, she is, yeah.
- And hopefully I pick one.
Make Brian happy.
- [Female Host] Mom, what
are you going to be looking
for today, in the girls?
- Kind first, and very nice,
and been positive in life.
Beautiful from in and out.
- I think I trust her, yeah.
(bouncy drum beat)
(ding)
- Oh my God, they're so cute.
There's already so many.
(ding)
(low pitched tone)
- My mom kind of swiped right on everyone.
I don't think she's ever
even heard of a dating app.
So, she's like, "everyone's
so nice, keep going."
So that was really fun to watch.
(low pitched tone)
(ding)
- [Female Host] Mom, you
kept a lot of people.
- I love them all!
(crowd laughs)
All right but, only one I
have to pick for the final.
- Yep, good luck.
(crowd laughs)
(energetic piano music)
All right, ready?
- So, let's do like this.
- Okay.
(camera clicks)
(crowd laughs)
- [Female Host] Mom, left or right?
(ding)
- I'm going, like, cute, so like-
- Cute.
- Face me.
- Okay.
- Touch me, or, can we touch?
- Can we touch?
Sure, all right, so, cute.
(camera clicks)
- My heart's pounding.
- Oh, same.
(low pitched tone)
(crowd laughs)
- Damn.
- Can we do like a side hug thing?
- Side hug?
- And then, like-
- Like hover hands?
- Yeah, like, well, like,
like that.
(camera clicks)
(crowd laughs)
(ding)
- We're at an event, we're
just, like, "Oh, camera."
Hi, camera.
- Oh, camera, hi.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
(camera clicks)
(ding)
- So I was wondering if I
could actually Titanic you.
Just on our arms back a little bit.
("My Heart Will Go On" music)
(camera clicks)
(ding)
- Nice, nice.
- So, I'm, like, short,
so would you be down
to piggy back ride?
- Sure.
- Woo!
(crowd laughs)
(camera clicks)
(low pitched tone)
(crowd laughs)
- Okay.
(camera clicks)
(low pitched tone)
(crowd laughs)
- Like a dinner and a cheersing.
- Okay.
- Cheers.
(camera clicks)
(ding)
- Going through, like,
a field-
- Oh, yes.
- One, two, three.
(camera clicks)
(crowd laughs)
(low pitched tone)
- Get low.
- Exactly, there you go.
(camera clicks)
(low pitched tone)
- So I kind of figured that we could just
skip ahead a little bit.
- Okay.
Could you get down on one knee?
(organ music)
(crowd laughs)
- Can't say no.
(camera clicks)
- Oh my God, yes!
(ding)
(crowd laughs)
- Three, two, one
- Three, two, one.
(camera clicks)
(ding)
- Okay.
- Go like this?
(camera clicks)
(ding)
- Maybe we could do something
to look like sidekicks.
- You're like the hero.
(kazoo music)
- Okay.
- I'll be the sidekick.
- Okay, perfect.
- All right?
(camera clicks)
(crowd laughs)
(ding)
- [Female Host] Good job, Mom.
- I tried my best.
(crowd laughs)
(playful music)
- Hi.
- I'm Charlotte.
- Nice to meet you.
I'm Fabiola.
- My name's Kirsten.
I'm super nervous.
- She's friendly, it's okay.
- How are you doing?
- I'm good, thank you.
(Jeri laughs)
- Go ahead and ask her.
- Tell me a little bit about you.
- So, my name is Xenia.
I'm originally from Russia
but I moved to Austria and now I'm here.
So I've been moving a lot.
I'm originally from Washington state,
so I love the outdoors.
- I go to Cal State Fullerton.
I'm studying mechanical
engineering with an art minor.
I made these shoes,
these are custom shoes.
- Wow.
- Whoa.
- It's like my frat 'cause I'm
in an engineering fraternity.
- [Brian] Oh yeah.
- I am also the president of
the fashion club at my school.
- Wow, that's really cool.
- And then I'm very athletic
and I like working out
and like going on adventures.
- I can tell.
(Cindy and Fabiola laugh)
- Thanks.
- I'm a creative person,
so I love painting, I love art, drawing,
playing guitar, and I love sports too.
- What kind of sport do you like?
- Basketball.
- Yes.
- Who's your team?
- Ooh, that's a tough one right now.
- There's only one right answer.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna say Warriors.
- Yeah, okay!
- Okay.
- Where's your hometown?
- Oh, my hometown? San Jose.
I don't know, are you Vietnamese?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, There's a lot of
Vietnamese people there.
- Yeah. I have relative live in San Jose.
- Oh yeah, It's really nice.
It's similar to Phu Quoc Dao.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh, you're Vietnamese?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Brian] Okay.
- Oh.
- [Estelle] Yeah.
- I love music and music
festivals and concerts.
- What was your last concert?
- I just went to Coachella actually.
- I was there too.
- Awesome. Weekend one or weekend two?
- Both.
- You went both weekends?
- I had to work there,
so that's why I was there.
- Oh my God.
- What's your plan for
after you've done school
and you're going to do the design?
- When I graduate, I plan
doing like engineering,
like solar panels and stuff.
After I get enough experience with that,
I'll just start designing my own products
and then I'll have like a
clothing line on the side too.
So-
- Busy.
- Stuff like that.
- Yeah, got a lot going on.
- Yeah.
- Entrepreneur stuff.
- Very good, business minded.
How many relationships do
you have before in the past?
- I've had two, like,
serious relationships.
One actually was with a woman
and I broke up with
her a little while ago.
We were just both not
mentally stable to be taking care
of each other in a relationship,
so we're both better now.
(Brian and Lola laugh)
- Oh my God.
- Are you uncomfortable?
- No.
- No, I'm not.
- It's good to know.
- I'm just waiting for
her to ask something.
- No, very nice to tell me about that.
Your honest to tell you-
- Yeah, yeah.
- About the past.
Yeah, I like that.
- Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I like to be honest.
That's important.
- Yeah, that's good.
- Yeah, good.
- Are you ready to date?
- Who?
(Jeri laughs)
- In, like, not, okay,
in general, in general.
Yeah, that was like, that sounded crazy.
Not like that.
- I mean, yeah.
If someone is,
you know.
- Oh my God.
If someone worthy enters the scenario,
which they haven't, but we'll see.
(lighthearted guitar music)
- Thank you.
(low pitched tone)
- I picked her.
- [Female Host] Oh you liked her?
- Yeah, yeah.
(ding)
- Keep this side?
- Yeah, keep is this way.
- Oh.
(ding)
- Thank you.
- Thank you,
it was nice meeting you.
- Yeah, very nice.
Thank you.
(ding)
- Bye.
- Thank you.
- [Female Host] Left or right?
- Oh, I forgot again, I'm sorry.
Yeah.
(ding)
- Right?
- Right, right.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
(ding)
- Okay.
- Okay, nice meeting you guys.
(ding)
- Nice to meet you, yeah.
- [Female Host] So how was that?
- You okay?
- Yeah.
- Brian, are you okay?
- It was all right.
- [Female Host] So, Mom, is
there anything you wanna say
to the girls before we pick?
- That you are all so beautiful
and if I don't you other does
not mean I don't like you.
I still like you a lot,
but I cannot get all.
This time my heart pound.
(crowd laughs)
- How was it?
- Good.
- I'm curious.
- I picked this one because
she was left minded,
you know.
- Oh yeah,
you love that.
- Creating, artist, yeah.
Artists to me, and then about fashion.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know, we love fashion, right?
- Yeah.
- That's why.
- She always said, like,
if she had a daughter,
she would take her shopping nonstop.
'Cause she loves fashion.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Female Host] Love it.
- Yeah.
(crowd laughs)
- We got it.
(smooth techno music)
- Hi.
Hi, how are you doing?
- I'm good, how are you?
- What was your name again?
- Fabiola.
- Fabiola, okay.
- Were you surprised?
- I had, like, no idea.
So, it's like, this is awesome.
- Cool.
(Brian and Fabiola laugh)
- Great pick.
Yeah, for sure.
- Do you like it?
Like, do you like-
- I mean.
(crowd laughs)
- [Cindy] I think I picked the one I like
more than him.
I'm sorry, my son.
- Oh my God.
- Hi babe.
- Family hug.
- You happy, babe?
- I'm happy.
- Family hug, family hug.
- You're happy, good.
- She said "fashion and business"
and I saw my mom, like, lit up.
But she's great, she seems really cool.
- [Female Host] Is she
who you would've selected
for yourself after today?
- Probably not, but I'm open to anything.
She's super creative.
I'm super creative too.
I love to chat, see where it goes, so.
- You said you like to shop?
- I do.
- She has, like, 10 closets.
- Because since back
home I was a dress maker
when I was very young.
Work, I always dress up.
I always, you know.
- Yeah.
- Customers say,
"I never see you wear the
same thing for 17, 20 years,"
you know?